you've talked about a survival of a
Nation
you yourself are a mortal being do you
contemplate your mortality
do you contemplate your death are you
afraid of death
aren't you yes who's not I mean if your
conscience
if you're a a a being with conscience I
mean one of the unhappy things about the
human brain is that it can contemplate
its own uh uh its own demise and so we
have to we all make our compromises with
this but I I think the question is what
lives on uh
what lives on Beyond us and I think that
you have to Define how much of uh of
posterity do you want to influence I
cannot influence
course of uh Humanity we are specs you
know little specks so that's not the
issue but in my case I've devoted my
life to a very defined purpose and that
is to assure the future
and security and
I would say permanence but that is
obviously a limited thing of the Jewish
State and the Jewish people I don't
think one can exist without the other
so I've devoted my life to that and I
hope that
in my time on this Earth and in my years
in office I'd have contributed to that
well you had one heck of a life
starting from uh MIT to six terms as
prime minister
thank you for this stroll through human
history and for this conversation it was
an honor thank you and I hope you come
back to Israel many times it's uh
remember it's the Innovation Nation it's
a robust democracy don't believe all the
stuff that you're being told it'll
remain that uh it cannot be any other
way and it's I'll tell you the other
thing
it's the best ally of the United States
and its importance is growing by the day
because our capacities in the
information world are growing by the day
we need a coalition of the like-minded
smarts
this is a smart Nation and we share the
basic values of freedom and liberty with
the United States so the Coalition of
the smarts
means Israel is uh
sixth eye and America has no better Ally
all right now off mic I'm going to force
you to finally tell me who's going to
win Elon Musk or Mark Zuckerberg but
that's uh that's a good time man we ran
out of time here I'll tell you outside